Почему Одни люди зарабатывают миллиарды
А другие
ничего у всех одинаковое количество
часов в сутках но результаты кардинально
отличаются это видео для тех кто устал
работать по 14 часов в день без
результата ваши результаты не растут Это
значит что вы застряли на одном уровне
Сегодня я расскажу вам как выйти за
пределы стеклянного потолка и достичь
нового уровня эффективности для того
чтобы пробить стеклянный потолок одного
таланта и усердия мало нужно мыслить и
делать по-другому либо делать совсем
другое как в шахматах выиграет не тот
кто сильнее а тот кто создал выигрышную
позицию поделите с этим видео с теми кто
готов к переменам и хочет выйти на новый
уровень они будут вам очень благодарны
[музыка]